a popular theory at this moment stated
sirs is going to be one of those
characters to die and it's all because
of her recently revealed pregnancy this
asserts his fourth child with her
brother Jamie and she stated that it
would be the first one where the
incestuous couple openly acts as the
legitimate parents a lot of Game of
Thrones fans are theorizing veteran
outsources pregnancy will lead into
Circe's death so I decided to provide as
accurate answer as there is vital
information we got from the previous
seasons this theory goes all the way
back to the famous valonqar prophecy
when which told young Cersei she would
be killed at the hands of the valonqar a
high Valyrian word translated to little
brother when stars his prophecies first
revealed in the fifth season a young
sirs is warned by a witch named Maggy
the Frog about the misery that awaits
her Maggie said even never read the
prince you will let the king
you'll be queen for a time then comes
another younger more beautiful to cast
you down and take all the hold dear
Meggie us revealed to Cersei that the
king will have twenty children and she
will have three gold will be their
crowns gold their shrouds almost all the
prophets already proved to be quite
accurate
Cersei did marry a king who fathered
many bastards Cersei had three children
all of whom died young more beautiful
Queen is in the midst of her conquest of
Westeros - all Cersei from the Iron
Throne although that's premature Maggie
told Cersei about her future in the show
there's an important aspect of the
prophecy from the books that could most
certainly mean that services pregnancy
will result with her own death in A Song
of Ice and Fire a series of epic fantasy
novel sandwhich Game of Thrones series
is based make his prophecy also includes
the line and when your tears have
drowned you the valonqar shall wrap his
hands about your pale white throat and
choke the life from you the main
suspects up until now have been sources
two younger brothers Tyrion and Jaime
but it seems that Circe's unborn son may
end up being the valonqar Cersei
sunburned son would be the little
brother to Cersei and Jaime Street that
children and therefore he could end up
killing Cersei in childbirth fulfilling
the prophecy of the valonqar this would
certainly be a strong tie to the wasters
his own mother died while giving birth
to Tyrion Cersei has always called him
responsible for their mother's death so
if this theory proves to be true beside
fulfilling the prophecy of the valonqar
it would also be some kind of justice
for Tyrion and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
calm
section down below